Hello world,
it's a Raj.
And today we're going to build a support
vector machine to classify two classes
of data.
I've already recorded this video before,
but I'm rerecording it because the sound
quality and the video quality was not
good. And we have a standard to
keep on this channel. So listen up.
Here we go.
We're going to build a support vector
machine to classify two classes of data,
right? And the way we're going to
optimize the support vector machine,
this type of machine learning model
is to use gradient descent. Okay?
So that's what we're going to do.
And this is what it looks like it,
it looks like this.
So say we've got two classes.
We have one class that's going to be
denoted by red dots and the other class is
going to be to noted by blue dots.
So if we were plucked both
classes on a two d graph,
an x y graph,
then we could draw a line,
a decision boundary that best
separates both of these classes.
And that line is called a hyperplane.
And our support vector machine
helps us create it. Okay?
That's what are support vector machine
helps us do and we're going to talk about
all the details of how this thing works,
but this is at a high level what it looks
like and we're going to build it with
just num Pi and nat plot
libe okay to graph it.
So no tensorflow or any of that.
All right,
so I hope you're as excited as I am for
this because we are going to go into the
theory as well as the code
as well. Okay, here we go.
So to start off with,
what are some use cases for an Svm?
So classification is one which we're
going to do and that is in fact the main
case that svms are used for.
That is the most popular case,
but they can also be used for other
types of machine learning problems.
Regression,
that is if we have some set of data points
and we're trying to predict the next
point in that set of data. So to stock
prediction would be a good example.
And also type Oracle also
called time series prediction.
There's also outlier detection.
So say you have a security system and
you're tracking all of your users and all
of your users have a set of metrics I
set of features that identifies them like
the time that they've logged
in and what they're doing.
There could be an anomaly and
you anomaly could be or bad guy,
the guy who's trying to break into your
security system and the spms help you
detect who that person is.
And there's also clustering but
we're not going to talk about which,
which is also um,
which is a form of unsupervised learning
learning as his outlier detection.
But we are going to do
supervised classification.
That is when our data has labels,
right?
We are trying to learn the mapping
between the labels and the data.
And if we learn the mapping,
that is a function.
The function represents the mapping,
the relationship between these variables.
If we learn this function, then where
machine learning model has done its job,
then we can use this function to plug
in some new input data and it's going to
output the prediction, right? And
this is all of machine really.
So let's look at the toe. In this example,
we're going to use toy data, right?
Because it's more, it's, it's about the,
it's about the math and the algorithms.
But I have these two other examples
for you just in case you want to do
something a little more useful.
So the first one is for handwritten
digit classification, right?
You have are we have a set of digits and
they all had their labels and we want
to learn the mapping between
the labels and the digits.
And so that's what this
repository will help us do.
And the great thing about this
repository is it's using psychic learn,
which is a very popular machine
learning library. In one line of code,
you could implement an Svn,
but we're going to implement it from
scratch because we want to learn how this
thing works.
But once you've done that,
then you can go on to using something
easier, something simpler like this. Okay?
And it's a real world use case.
I've got one more example here that I've,
that I have for you guys.
And that's where pulse classification.
So the idea is that for a human given,
some metrics like their age and their eye,
what was the other one?
Their pulse rate. Obviously we can
predict what their emotions will be.
So it's emotion classification and we're
using an SVM in this repository as well
as well as psych yet learned
to implement that STM.
So check out those two repositories once
you really understand the math behind
support vector machines from this video
and from the associated code. Okay. So,
uh, yeah, so those are two other examples.
So how does this thing compare to the
other machine learning algorithms?
And there are so many of them.
There are random forests,
there are neural networks.
Well, as a rule of thumb,
svms are great if you have small datasets.
So I'm saying like a thousand
rows or less of data, right?
1,000 data points or less.
If we have that,
then svms are great for classification
and they are very popular.
However, other algorithms, random
forests, deep neural networks,
et Cetera,
require more data,
but almost always come up
with a very robust model.
And the decision of,
of which classifier to use depends
on both your problem and your data.
And as you build this
mathematical intuition,
all of these choices will
become very clear to you.
So we're starting off with the
support vector machine. Okay?
And so I also have this quote by this
famous a computer science professor,
Donald Knuth,
who now I know the chaos silent
Donald Knuth who said that premature
optimization is the root of all evil
or at least most of it in programming.
And what does he mean by that?
That means if you can make a performance
gain by using something way more
complicated,
like a deep neural network,
but it's only going to be like it's
only going to be by like 0.1% then it's
unnecessary.
Your time as a programmer is very
valuable and you will only want to do the
minimum amount of work that you have to,
to get the results that you want.
So if you're trying to use a neural
network for problem that only requires
something very simple,
like a support vector machine,
you should use the support vector machine,
not the deep neural network,
just because it's hot and
it's outperforming everything
else almost all the time
because it requires more
computing data and way more, uh,
it requires more computing power and
way more data, right? Two things, um,
which if you don't have, don't use it,
use a support vector machine, right?
These are all methods of intelligence.
This is all about the
math of intelligence.
And there are many ways to approach it.
So what is a support vector machine?
So this thing can be used
for both classification is
that this is it, this is it.
This and regression got these points.
What's the next point in a series?
So given two or more
labeled classes of data,
remember we are using supervised learning.
It can create a discriminative
classifier that is a classifier that can
discriminate between different classes.
Is it this, is it this is it this?
Right? And the opposite to
discriminative, by the way, is generative.
Where we generate new data.
We take some training data variated very
it in some way using our model and that
output is very similar to the
train data but it's novel data.
But that's for later on anyway.
So the way we build this hyperplane
and we'll talk about that term,
but the way we build
this hyper plane or line,
this decision boundary between the classes
is by maximizing the margin that is
the space between that line
and both of those classes.
What do I mean by that?
When I say both of those classes,
what I actually mean are the points in
each check out this image or the points
and each of those classes that are
closest to the decision boundary and these
points are called support vectors.
Okay.
We call them support vectors
because they are vectors.
They are data point vectors that support
the creation of this hyperplane that
are support vector machine.
We'll create, right?
So we are maximizing the margin.
And why do we do that?
Because we want to draw a line
that is in the absolute perfectly,
that perfect middle spot between
both of these sets of data such as,
so that when we plot a new data point,
if,
if it is of a certain class,
it will have the maximum likelihood of
falling on that side of the decision
boundary where it should.
And the only way to do that,
to maximize the space with which a new
data point can fall into its correct
class category is to maximize the space
between data points and put a line right
in the middle of that space. You see
what I'm saying? I can't get feedback,
but I'm just going to assume that, that,
that that was intuitive, right? So right,
so small margin,
we're maximizing the margin and
we're Tryna draw a decision boundary,
a line of best,
not a line of best fit,
but align of best classification
between both of those.
And we call this line a hyperplane.
Okay. So what is a hyperplane?
Well, I hyperplane is a decision
surface. So given end dimensions, right?
So let's say our data is end dimensional,
where n is the number of features that
you have length with high tongue color,
tongue color.
Where did that come from?
Tongue color and skin color and
whatever other colors. And so,
um,
a hyperplane is n minus one dimensions.
So if you have a two dimensional graph
where, just like this on the left,
right here where I'm pointing my mouse,
we're with this,
our symbol with a two exponent
denotes a two dimensional graph.
A hyperplane would then be two minus one,
right? And minus one. So one dimension.
So it would be a lie, right? But if,
if we are in three dimensional
space or are two the three,
then a hyperplane is going to be two
dimensional because it's three minus one,
which is to, right? So we
have a plane and so you,
we can extrapolate this to
many dimensions. So if we
had a 400 dimensional space,
which we often do in machine learning,
our data doesn't just have two
or three features. It has many,
many features, right? It's not so
neatly packaged for us to visualize.
And that's where techniques
like dimensionality reduction
and all this come into
play,
which we'll talk about.
But right now if we have
a 400 dimensional space,
a graph of points than a hybrid
plan would be 399 dimensions,
which we can't really visualize.
I mean, think about it, humans,
we are not that good at visualizing
or in fact it's impossible for us to
visualize anything and
more than three dimensions.
But for machines it's very easy. It's very
intuitive and that's all that matters.
As long as our machine is able to draw
this decision boundary of n minus one
dimensions,
then given some new data point,
if we put it into that model, that
functions, that functions, um,
if we put it into that function,
if we plug it in and it's going to output
the correct class of whatever it is.
Okay, so, and this actually
comes from geometry.
So I guess there is a little bit
of geometry in machine learning,
right? So nonlinear versus linear. Well,
we're only going to talk about linear
classification because nonlinear
classification is more
complicated and we'll get to that.
But the idea here is that
let's say you have some, uh,
some sets of data, some,
some two datasets, right? Two
classes of data, the best,
let's say the best,
uh,
the line that best separates these
two classes of data isn't linear.
Let's say it's got curves like in this,
in this example right here,
how are we supposed to build a
hyperplane like that? It would, well,
it would be more complicated and there
is actually a trick to do this called the
kernel trick and we'll talk about that
later. But there's a way to take that map,
that input space into a feature space
such that the hybrid plan that you draw is
linear even though it
wouldn't be otherwise.
And so that's called the kernel trick
and we'll talk about that later, right?
So we're only talking about
linear classification for
support vector machines,
supervised linear classification, right?
As opposed to unsupervised. Anyway,
there's so many different ways that
we can frame this problem, right?
There's so many different ways we can
frame the learning process and more will
be discovered. He was a very exciting time
to be in this field. Okay. So let's get,
let's go ahead and uh, get to
building shall we? But first of all,
I also want to say a one more thing.
So no matter what model you're using,
a random forests and support vector
machine, a deep neural network,
in the end we are approximating, we
are guessing, uh, iteratively close.
We are getting,
we're educated guests.
I'm trying to think of a
different word for approximation,
but we are approximating a function,
right? We are trying to find what is the,
what is that optimal function and that
function represents the relationship
between all the variables in our
data, right? That function is,
that is that is that relationship.
It's that mapping and if we can find
that function then we have learned,
we have learned from our data and so every
machine learning model under the hood
is just a function that we are trying to
approximate and it's coefficients are,
it's weights and they are
being updated over time,
through some optimization technique.
Be that gradient descent
usually or Newton's method,
which we'll learn about or you know,
whatever it is. Okay. So, yeah,
so whatever it is, we're just trying
to approximate a function, right?
This is a way of thinking approximating
a function, whatever we're using,
decision forest, whatever we're using,
it's all about approximating a function.
Decision. Trees. All right,
so let's go ahead and get and
get to building, right? So
first we're going to uh,
important num pi and so num Pi is going
to help us perform math operations,
matrix math and then we're going to
plot our data using map plot line. Okay,
so this first step is for
us to define our data.
So our data is going to be of this form x,
y bias.
So the first, so they're five
data points here, right there,
five data points and we've got the x
coordinate the y coordinate and we've just
input our bias into our data to make
things easier later on. But we can,
for all intensive purposes,
ignore this bias term,
but we are basically just
ha we had these set of x,
y coordinate Paris that we can plot on a
graph and each of these data points has
an associated label,
an output label.
That output label is either a
negative one or a one. Okay.
So for the first two,
they're going to be negative one.
And for the last three they're going
to be one. So these last three,
so what we can do is we can plot
these examples on a two d graph.
Okay? So we can say, let's plot the,
let's plot the first two with the negative
marker and let's plot the last three
with the positive marker. Okay? And
so when we plot, it looks like this.
And what we're also going to
do is we're going to print as,
we're going to plot a possible hyperplane
that is a hyperplane that is just the
line. And we don't know,
it's just our naive guests.
We don't know if it's the optimal
hyperplane. In fact it's not,
but it just so happens to perfectly
separate our training data classes.
Just so for us to just see
what it looks like, right?
This is just for that
example. Okay, so that's that.
So now what we can do is get into the
math. So I hope you're ready for this.
All right, so let's get into
our calculus. All right,
so right machine learning machine
learning is all about optimizing for an
objective function.
And the way we optimize for an objective
function is by minimizing a hope.
You said loss or error function,
because that is the correct answer.
We are minimizing a loss for air function.
So let's go ahead and first
define our loss function.
Our loss function in this case is
going to be called the hinge loss.
So the hinge loss is a very popular
type of loss function for support vector
machines.
Okay.
And the class of algorithms that support
vector machines fall under our maximum
margin classification algorithms,
right?
We are trying to maximize the margin
that is the distance between classes such
that we can draw the best,
uh,
decision boundary between those classes
that best separates both of those
classes. Okay, so this
is what it looks like.
This is what the hinge loss looks like.
The hinge loss looks like
this with the word. See,
that's how we did note the hinge loss.
Given these three terms,
the three terms are going
to be x, Y, and f of x,
where x is the sample data.
Why is the true label and f
of x is the predicted label,
right? So it's going to be
one minus y times F of x,
and this little plus sign down here
just means that if this result,
if the result of this op,
these sets of operations is negative,
then we're going to just set it to zero
because we always want the results to be
positive,
okay?
So what this means is that we can break
this down into this equation right here
where my,
where my mouse is now over where we can
say if y times F of x is greater than or
equal to one,
which would make this come out to be one
minus a number that's greater than one,
which would be zero or a negative number,
then set the result to zero because we
want it to be positive. And if it's not,
then it's going to be some non negative
number greater than zero. Okay?
So that's our loss. That's how we
define our loss. And remember these,
this why and this f of x. Both of
these values, the scalar values,
these single values are going to be a
single number, right? And that's what,
that's why we can multiply them.
And so our objective function then is
going to consist of the loss function,
which noticed how it looks a
little different, but it's,
it's really the same thing. This
one minus y times x, uh, XW.
It's the same as this lost up here.
It's just a different way of denoting it.
And we can say the sigma term means that
we are we to take a sum of terms where
the number of terms is n and n is the
number of data points that we have.
So for all five data points,
we'll find the loss of each of those data
points using this, this loss function,
the hinge loss,
and we'll sum them all up together.
And that that total sum will
represent our total loss for our data,
right? That's a single number.
It's going to be a single number.
And then once we have that, we're
going to define our objective function.
So our objective function,
in this case,
it's going to be denoted by this men
lambda w okay, with the square sign.
And so what is this?
All right,
so our objective function is going to
be denoted by the loss plus this regular
riser term, which is denoted right
here with this men and the lambda.
So a regular riser is,
is a tuning knob.
And what the regular
riser does is it tells us
how best to fit our data.
So if the regular riser term is too high,
then our model will be over
fit to the training data.
And it's not going to generalize
well to new data points.
It's going to be over fit,
but at the regularize or term is too low,
then our model is going to be under fit.
So that means going to be to generalize
and it will have your large training
error.
So we need the perfect regularize
or term two for our model to be as
generalizable as possible and fit to our
training data. It's that balance term,
right? And it says it's also, it's
also comes out to be a single scalar.
So given our weights are we square
that? Um, and then we use this lamp,
lend the term here. Uh, we multiply
by the, by this slime to term. Okay.
So, um, right?
So that's our objective function or
objective function consists of our regular
riser and our loss function.
We add them both together.
So what we wanna do is we want
to optimize for this objective.
And by optimizing for this objective,
we're going to find the optimal regularize
their term, and we're going to, uh,
minimize a loss.
So we're going to do two things
by optimizing for this objective.
And so the way we're going to optimize
is we're going to perform gradient
descent,
right?
And so the way we're going to perform
gradient descent is by taking the partial
derivative of both of these two
terms of both of these terms.
We're going to take the partial
derivative of the regular riser,
and we're going to take the partial
derivative of the, um, of the loss term.
Okay? So this is what
it looks like, right?
So remember from the power
rule for partial derivatives,
all we have to do is move the power to
the coefficient and then subtract one
from the coefficient.
And then for the other term we do the,
we do the same thing.
And so for the last term we do the same
thing and it comes out to this and so
it's, it's going to be zero or it's going
to be negative y times x. So there's a,
there's a case for both of them.
Okay.
Okay. So then what we, what we then
have is a misclassification condition.
Any classification condition.
So we can, so we can,
so basically we can say
if it's misclassified,
so if we miss classify our data
depending on these partial derivatives,
then we can update our weights
a certain way. And what I'm,
what do I mean by certain way?
I mean we can update our weights by
using both the regular riser term and the
loss function term. Okay.
Because this isn't zero,
it's going to be negative y times
x, but else, yeah. If, if we,
if we have correctly classified,
then this value is going to be zero.
It's going to be a zero.
So we don't need to update our loss.
We only update our reg. We only update
our weights using our regular riser term.
And so this term right here is
a learning rate, by the way.
So it's weights plus learning
rate times the regular riser term.
The learning rate, by the
way, is how we, um, it's our,
is another tuning knob for
how we, uh, how fast we learn.
So if the learning rate is too high, as
our model is learning, it could just,
it could just miss, it could just
overshoot that minimum entirely.
You could just keep going,
but if it's too low,
you can take way too long to converge,
or in fact, a good, just never converge.
So we want to have that
optimal learning rate. Okay?
So those are our terms.
And so now,
mmm,
now let me plug into some
power here. Okay, so then,
so now let's get into the code for this,
right? We've talked about the math.
Let's get into the code. So for the
code part, we can say, all right, well,
we want to initialize a
support vector machine.
We're going to perform stochastic
gradient descent, by the way,
but we're going to initialize a support
vector machine with a set of wage
factors and he's weight factors are
the coefficient of the model that we're
trying to approximate.
There are three values that we
initialized with a set of Zeros.
Then we have a learning rates,
which has won a number of epox,
which is a number just iterations to
train for over the Dataset over the entire
Dataset.
And then a list of errors we're going
to store all of our errors in. Okay.
So basically we could say,
and now here's the machine learning part.
Here's all of that math that we just did.
We can fit into these 10 lines of code,
right?
We are literally just
taking those equations and
converting them into code right
now.
So we'll say for the number of epochs for,
so for 100,000 times we'll set up an
error to initially zero let's iterate
through every single data point that
we have. So for all five data points,
so we have five data points.
We're going to iterate through
all of them 100,000 times. Okay.
And so then we have our first case,
which is the misclassification case.
So in the misclassification case,
let's see what that was.
Y times x w is less than one.
This is exactly what it comes
out to programmatically.
Why Times the dot product of acts
in w is when it's less than one.
So if it's less than one,
then we have misclassified our data so we
can update our weights using that full.
A equation that we saw were right up here,
right up here where we're using both our
regular riser and our loss function to
update weights, right?
Because this is non zero,
it's going to be negative y times
x using our partial derivatives.
And our Parkville derivatives are
the gradient, right? They are the,
they are the gradient value that so
that we can update our weights in a
direction such that such that the
such that the error is minimized.
That's what they're going to help us do.
Okay.
And so we'll update our weights
doing that and then we'll say,
well we got an error,
so let's make our error account one else.
If we've correctly classified,
then we update our weights using
just the regular riser term,
which is one over the number of epochs.
By the way, are regularize a term.
I think I might've forgotten to say that
our regular riser term is one over the
number of epochs.
So it's inversely correlated so that the
regular riser parameter will decrease
as a number of epochs increase.
And so the update rule for correct
classification looks like this.
We're only using the regular riser
term. All right? So we've got that.
And so once we have that, we can
plot it out and we'll also, uh,
add all those errors to this list of
errors. So we just have that, you know,
we want to see how the error frequency
decreases over time during training.
That's the actual machine learning.
And so when we plot that,
we'll see that the error decreases over
time. The air value decreases over time,
and that's what we want, right?
So we've trained our model, right?
We've trained it on those
five toy data points.
And so now what we can do is
we can now plot this model.
We can plot this model and uh,
we can,
we can add testing data as
well. Bright. But we have it,
we had a misclassification case and we
had a correct classification case and
depending on whether he was
misclassified or classified correctly,
we updated or weights using
a different strategy. Okay.
And the whole goal is to make
those weights the optimal
values that they should
be such that our error value is minimized.
And we have the equations
for that right here.
And the reason we took the
partial derivative derivative
is so that we can best
up there weights to optimize
for our objective function,
which consists of these two terms,
minimizing the loss and optimizing the
regular riser term such that our data is
best fit to both our training data and
any novel data points we give it. That is,
it's generalize ability, right.
So hopefully that all makes sense.
That's essentially what we just did. If
you, if you understood like 80% of that,
pat yourself on the back because you are
a boss. All right. We are all bosses.
All right. So machine learning
bosses. Okay. So back to this.
Okay. So now we're going to plot this
data. All right, so let's plot it.
So if we have less than two sample exam
samples, then we'll apply it again.
So this is the same thing that
we did before. So we'll do,
we'll do it again and then we're
going to add our test samples.
So our test samples are going to be just
two points and they're also going to be
two toy data points.
But just assume that we know what
class this data points, you know,
consist of until add our two test samples,
plot our hyperplane that train on the
training data and hopefully it classifies
both the training data and the testing
data accurately such that they all lie on
the perfect,
uh,
side of the decision boundary so
that they are correctly classified.
And so when we plot it,
we'll see that that is the case.
All the positive labeled data points
are on one side of the line and all the
negative label data points are
on the other side of the line.
We have correctly classified both
our training and our testing data by
optimizing for our objective.
And by doing so,
we are minimizing our hinge loss so
that we maximize the margin or the space
between the two data classes so that we
can draw the optimal hyperplane and we
use a regular riser term that we also,
uh,
found the optimal value for
it by including it in the
objective function so that
our model was best fit to both the
training and the testing data. All right.
So that in a nutshell is how
support vector machines work.
So, um, two
to go over, uh, this again,
let me just say that.
Okay.
Right. So the gradient is a vector whose
components consist of the derivative.
So in all of Calculus we have derivatives.
And so the reason we take the derivative
is because calculus is this is the math
of the rate of change. We want to know
how something changes and the way we,
we study how it changes.
We use it in physics a lot
to write for moving bodies.
The derivative is how
we is, is, is how we is,
how we understand which direction and
something is moving in, right? It's,
we derive the direction from it.
And there's several ways of representing
the derivative. In Calculus, we use the,
obviously the derivative,
which is the derivative operator,
but then we also use the gradient
operator. And so the gradient,
and so you hear these terms a lot,
you hear gradient and you
hear derivative a lot,
but they're really the same thing in
that the gradient is a vector whose
components consist of the partial
derivatives of whatever coefficients of
whatever function that we're
trying to approximate. Okay.
And so that's the gradient and
the derivative and [inaudible].
In the next week's lesson,
we're going to talk about the Jacobian,
which is a matrix of first order partial
derivatives and also the Hessian,
which is a matrix of the second
order partial derivatives.
And these are all words that represents
how we organize and represent change in
data in in functions, right? And we,
the reason we want to represent change
is so that we can minimize her loss,
we can optimize for an objective,
we can iteratively get closer and closer
to approximating to educatedly guessing
what the optimal function is. So that we
learned the mapping between data points.
Okay. So, hopefully that all made sense.
All right, so that's it for this lesson.
Please subscribe for
more programming videos,
and for now I'll get to go invent a new
type of Svm. So thanks for watching.